[Music]
what's going through the laundry found
these new phones for me tonight I'm
tearing these off with my teeth like an
old school cartoon gonna go honey Mitch
does your daughter's I'm ready you look
beautiful I used to hold that girl in
the palm of my hand
Kayla's becoming a woman you're gonna
have to deal with that thanks dad why
are you here you think I'm gonna miss
the most important that of your young
life there's my graduation graduation is
for losers tonight is the first night of
our adult lives I want to go to prom and
lose my goddamn virginity prom night
it's kind of perfect I'm in Julie left
her laptop open you just didn't want our
kids all emojis have a secret meaning Oh
eggplants are dicks this is some kind of
a dick related agreement our girls are
not thinking things through I may stop
them I'm in I'm fully planning on having
sex to me wherever the night takes us
the night's gonna take us there
wherever the wind sails our ships your
ship is going into my Harbor
they're generally wwvv deep what would
Vin Diesel do hey fast miss furious is
completely unrealistic it's not a
documentary I get that
[Music]
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about chugging contest
bring it no no right we're but Chucky
on the count of three
they got a lager or an IPA does he gun
doesn't matter
oh my god he's just be spit-roasting
himself are you a team player or aren't
you
I just Chum 240 with my [ __ ] I'm a
team player
[Music]